very great pleasure very great pleasure
to introduce the closing plenary session
and the person who will introduce the
plenary speaker professor elliptically
Raj Thank You Tamaki and it's a
particularly great pleasure for me to
introduce Gopal we have known each other
for a very very long time he studied at
JNU I thought I'd change around the
early years of jr. he is now a professor
of Indian politics at the Center for
Political Studies in JNU I don't want to
stand between you and him for very long
he started at the University of orange
about appropriately Ambedkar it's a
millionth college the college that you
found it he did his BA and MA there and
he got his MPhil and PhD from Jawaharlal
Nehru University he has published three
books the first is called vernacular
Buddhism published in 1997 the second is
acts of fear of Dali politics 2005 at
the last one which he gave me yesterday
it's an edited book called humiliation
claims and context and say couple of
words about that later on this was
published just recently by the Oxford
University Press in Delhi in 2009 he has
also had a very interesting conversation
with soon Desilu chi in the pages of the
EPW which some of you might have
followed in September 2009 where he
wrote sir Luke I wrote a paper on the
phenomenology of untouchability and
Gopal wrote rejoinder to that with the
intriguing title the archaeology of
untouchability it's a particular
pleasure for me to introduce Gopal not
merely because of the length of time
that we go back together but I have
learnt a great deal from Gopal from
long conversations with him and what I
have learned most poignant ly I think
and most powerfully is to think about
the particular physicality the kind of
body leanness of artists ability which
people who are who experience that body
less and people who do not who only
tried to experience get into it
intellectually is a kind of ontological
bar between the true sides which is very
very hard to cross this is linked to
something you know which I should
confess publicly I was one of the
participants in this conference and I
want you to I want to tell you a little
bit about the conference because I think
that would show you the distinctiveness
of ghopal thinking he told me once that
you know in what I learnt in JNU and
through conversations etc the people
like you gave us a lot of conceptual
tools to think about exploitation with a
Jane who was an institution which was
very heavily influenced by Marxism the
highly sophisticated forms of Marxism
about exploitation and operation but you
didn't actually help us think about
humiliation which is the different
category and one of the tasks of this
conference was explicitly I think gopal
wrote no to everybody who came to the
conference saying that I want you to
write a paper on humiliation and I want
it not to be on exploitation or
oppression so that we can find the way
you know conceptual way of getting into
it which is exceedingly hard and what I
have the conference is that I was one of
the participants in that conference it
was one of the most enriching
conferences that I have participated in
but eventually I failed to write the
paper not simply because of lack of time
and lack of discipline which is true but
but I found it exceedingly hard you know
to get into the problem from the kind of
techniques and tools that I possess now
I also wanted to tell you very briefly
about the significance I think of
couples work
I think Gopal has made very serious
contributions in three fields I also
believe that we are probably on the cusp
of a change in Dalit studies in India we
have had a lot of very interesting work
on on untouchability the history of the
Dalits Ambedkar and things like that but
I have a feeling that we have exhausted
the earlier types of questions and the
earlier types of techniques and what
they could yield in understanding this
very very important phenomenon of Indian
history and society and I think we are
sort of collectively sort of groping
towards a new set of questions new set
of techniques and things like that and I
think in three of those gopal has
actually made a very significant
contribution in my view the first of
those is through his participation in
policy questions but which involved very
large questions about finishing the idea
of social justice and things like the
debate about subcategorize ation of
reservations in other pradesh
particularly he participated lee
energetically and i think with great
clarity of thought in some of those
questions i think he is bringing out
this book humilation
should constitute an important
contribution to the conceptual
conceptual discussions about the problem
of untouchability precisely this
emphasis on the distinction distinction
does not mean that they don't go
together or these do not actually exist
convicts Lee and the complicatedly in
the lives of the same individuals of
course they go together but I think it's
it's also possible to make a very strong
analytical case that we should learn to
think about these three concepts
separately of operation exploitation and
humiliation so I consider this book
which has a very distinguished set of
authors it's very important and finally
I think in many of the discussions that
I have recently attended part of this
conference some of which I have attended
the conference in our department
recently by Anupama Rao and many others
I think we are actually going back to
some of the very interesting and deep
questions in Ambedkar zone intellectual
biography and the shift in Ambedkar to
I think is something which needs to be
taken very seriously it's an extremely
complex and deep question because to my
mind as the political theorist it
actually constitutes sort of choice and
I'm not very clear what the nature of
Ambedkar choice was but he was certainly
aware that he could make a choice or he
could actually refuse to make a choice
and speak both the languages but there's
a very deep difference between the
language of liberalism which wants to
obstruct the force of social injustice
the practice of untouchability by the
force of the state so this is one way of
dealing with it this is one meaning of
stopping untouchability or preventing
untouchability but there's also always
the other possibility which is the
Gandhian meaning of the possibility of
stopping untouchability which is because
untouchability exists not merely in the
lives of the untouchables but also in
the minds and the lives of the hindrance
so eradication of untouchability might
mean on a certain interpretation not
merely stopping it by force forcing
people who have untouchability in their
mind not to show it in their actual
conduct but something deeper you know
which is the eradication of
untouchability and i think this question
is goes on continually in the debate
between Guardian Ambedkar and it's it's
reflected in the Ambedkar choice of
conversion to Buddhism later on so I
think it's a very very interesting
question of the two languages the
language of liberalism which uses one
kind of categories and the language of
Buddhism religion compassion etc which
uses quite different types of categories
so I think Gopal is also making
important contribution to that so with
that please join me in extending a very
warm welcome to Gopal guru
dear friends both female and male I
should thank pseudo for giving this very
real privilege to me by way of
introducing me to this very very
important and enlightened gathering in
this holler I now realized that why so
you didn't write for this volume I kept
on writing thinking that didn't you
should tell me what I pursued and I
think I've spent more time in forcing
him than anybody 1,000 but anyway it's a
great pleasure to pursue things with
Luther you guys when you get something
when we push him so I was not losing it
salute well I again something he's time
you tell me that why you are not writing
and their reasoning itself so I think
it's a it's it's again and maybe
sometime later I if I'm right of writing
a rejoinder to the soul why are you
later I will I will write that personal
comes conversation with you
with your permission so I thank you very
much for your a kind was for me I assume
this is demand that I should also thank
the organizers for inviting me to to
first share my views with you and and
and and for having you and me a opposed
need to really listen to several
speakers since yesterday I think it was
a very very rewarding and the reach
experience that I have had since
yesterday so I am really thankful to the
commit the organizing committee
particularly I do not know name that an
embarrass them but I really thank them
for this opportunity
I should also take this opposed need to
thank this Parekh not the foundation for
inviting the first professor of this
and I'm going to be around for two weeks
and likely to bore you and this is a
warning so hope please bear with me I'll
be making noise here and there but thank
you for that very very rare opportunity
that you have project with me I had come
here and Liguria you know what it'd be
in 2003 I think and then I had a
exciting time with the participants and
the scholars icepick so I spoke
something on theoretical diamonds and
empirical shoe drugs so that was a
starting I started this phrase from
Columbia actually so I develop over a
period of time and then it was published
me furtively later not I don't want to
spend more time on my own personal it
just let me get back to what I'm trying
to say today the title would I have
title representation like is there an
ideal in is there an idea of ideal in
Ambedkar some of you might really
question as to why I'm starting with a
question is there an idea of ideal in
Ambedkar and as LOC has already given
some clue in the morning there ought the
question of art is an ideal in Ambedkar
I think that's a very that's a that's a
very interesting starting point so I
would like to build on to the the inside
that I got since yesterday and I will
try to also join issues with people who
spoke about different dimensions of
America's contribution to our thinking
imagination politics of transformation
and emancipation what I'm raising this
question is a problem I see a problem
this question unless you really raise
this question you will not be able to
really decide the epistemic status of a
thinker it is only through this ideal
you you did it in a judge that I think a
person is a thinker
so that's see that's the this is the
standard through which you can really
decide the normative capacity of
unlike Ambedkar if there's no idea I've
already hinting I don't know if it is
policy and then I think the estimate
character will go down so I think I'm
not even making a choice between policy
and ideal and I am suggesting already
that policy cannot be an ideal it's a
very proactive statement I'm making
where we can come back and discuss so I
think the question is so important that
you had to use this notion of ideal to
declare or adjust their hamburger was
wise was a thinker and if you don't if
you fail to raise this question then I
think the tragedy with Ambika roadway
that he is reduced to a Delhi thinker a
leader or a constitutional maker I mean
this a morning session yesterday's
morning session the question therefore
I'm asking is was he a simply
Constitution maker was he a leader of
the Dalit what was he a strategist what
was it and therefore I think it is
synthesis is a tragic question that is
associative the Ambedkar and not it's
not the father of a traitor
it is the problem with those people who
actually as nucleus duck has really very
brightly when our cast of mind the
question of a larger question a question
of locating ideally remember it doesn't
really occur to this cast of mind and
therefore I would say in Toni Morrison's
words as blacks in the u.s. who do not
grow in the eyes of whites similarly I
bet that doesn't grow in the eyes of the
Brahmans or upper caste in India it's a
bit theoretical statement I am making
him know that but the reality is that if
you you always see that in pages you
know Ambedkar was a reader of the
release he was a strategies and he was a
constitution makers but that's nothing
that little unsure
this is this worth I think therefore in
order to really assign a kind of a full
and final recognition to embed careers
to be raised this question of what is
the ideal in Ambedkar
and that's why I think I chosen this
type this question also has a model
significance is there an idea of ideally
none better
this also has a model significance on
why I'm saying this is there is a model
significance to this question because
first some good reasons I'm great care
has not become a fashion luckily
therefore you know I okay also I also
work on America's ideal and that's fine
at this fashion I'm also America hasn't
become a penchant for fascination just
to say no you have I America's ideal and
you also have ideals of others Plato
Aristotle and Gandhi perhaps and then I
will take pleasure in comparing
America's I deal with other ideals and
so I I feel fascinated so you know where
I consume my consume Ambedkar through
fascination but there is a tragic side
to this as well their file introduced
third town fashion fascination and
freight and I'm approaching the question
of ideal through the quest through the
through the through the through the
through faith now why I am saying that
is afraid because there is a there is a
ruthless denial of this ideal innovator
and identically from the Gandhian and I
will name them and under I'm the I think
I think we had to name between is gone
of this conversation one with that one
has to have engaged not only in the
transfer and conversation but also
honest conversation and that is what he
has been teaching us right from 77 I
hope he doesn't disown me as a student
so I think that's that's the problem
with the car wash it has to be there and
the conversation has to be honest I
would name them this ironical deserve
guardians were very ruthless
denying this idea by idly none better
secondly there is a absolute denial and
really skillful denial of ideally none
better
and this denial is very skillful in the
saying that they don't deny that is no
ideal in Ambedkar but it plays a
secondary role to the superior ideal
which is sitting in the West and there
are some scholars there are some
scholars here in this hall and I'll make
a special reference to Christopher's
twins understand
we haven't changed sir you aren't change
I haven't changed my own hoop in about
since 1997 so so that is the
subordination of ideal of America to the
Western as a superior and the third one
is about there's also a denial of ideal
in Ambedkar through now you
understanding Ambedkar by the lips now I
have not explained as to how this
there's a very a very varying degree of
denial in all the three positions let me
therefore find out how this three levels
of denial really is doing damage to the
idea which is very much there this were
very very noted banyan in India is still
inferential professor KJ Shah was the
Andean professor terawatt must be
knowing and he very painful compared
with Gandhi said Gandhi opposes the idea
after Rama Raja because his commitment
to the human good was impeccable and
there is a consistency in this
commitment with a human good so the
concern is universal therefore here in
Gandhi Ubik what happens Universal
at the concern for universal human
becomes ideal and he says compared to
Gandhi Ambedkar is narrow thanks on
about 1 liter delete I quoted that I'm
not throwing something from dish you got
something from a pocket is there all
references are there if somebody is in
the interest rate I can show those their
references and you trust me please
so the notion of sacrifice
Sehwa and self-purification and Gandhi
becomes an ideal for KJ's Shah and
compared to Gandhi Ambedkar doesn't have
that commitment that sacrifice that and
that that vision for this for the human
human being human good now one can
really divide this but I think this one
very very high this is very American
Gandhi Gandhi wouldn't tell wouldn't
really use these words actually Gandhi
the relationship with between Gandhi and
amber Carroll has been a very very
complicated nature we simplify it for
our own reasons you politicize it for
the wrong reasons but the relationship
between the two is complicated and I
think it's a different issue of debate
and we can take it out later some of the
equation so that's one the other one is
very interesting professor Aseema son
who was a who is still around he is
thought to fill political TV in Bombay
no city and got it hadn't settled in
Chennai he wrote in one of the very
leading generals in in Maharashtra that
Ambedkar doesn't have an ideal because
all the time what America was doing I
got according to him was to really make
a reference to the past to organize
thorin action for the moment he suggests
Reena Morrison suggests that he shooter
really made a reference to the universal
principles which are there embodied in
Thomas Paine and Jefferson and Jefferson
and Thomas spend are the ideal for
seniors and and which Ambedkar fails to
follow now the question and I think the
debate and somebody was making a fire
yesterday he there should be the rupture
between his tea and there should be D
linking between his TM and present
contemporary I think this or this is a
very wrong way of really looking at
the historical questions upon touch
ability and caste now seniors and is
suggesting that look here you you have
to forget the past though don't have any
reference an atomistic past because you
have ideals already sitting in the West
why don't you follow it
Ambika refuses to follow the other ways
of seeing us in any way and that's why
he's ideally emerges to the historical
navigation there's no other route and
that's why I mean I agree with somebody
who stages a tabula rasa no it's not a
clean slate there there are historical
roots fool a and I'm bet there are
cookie that in owning of Buddhism and
their source of imagination and
challenges they confront is Buddhism
puts up them and that such fool a
becomes the guiding force for America
has forbidden goes up puts so I think
that that's the problem would see my son
but I would like to ask one more
question as to why people advise
Ambedkar not to go to the past because
past has delicate details about the
wrongdoings and you don't want really
one of those delicate details that
that's what this by past past and I
would have you really had a great anthem
it is true it is only through existing
shall ISM you find the difficult
questions and New York now I will also
later talk about what is the principle
of poor responsibility but I think
that's a politics of really suggesting
kind of a universalism Trombetta
it's a politics of universalism you
might ask the question parameter whether
there is any Universal in Ambedkar we
listen and I'm doing that I'm going to
discuss some something about it later
you are still my teacher
at the so this is one about the waist
and that please cord as I said pristine
and I think study your weight
complicated position you develop you
know article and I would discuss with
you please rectify if I'm really not
representing your views faithfully
please rectified it but there are true
soul says I would like to quote here and
it's a Columbia University professor and
an M reach this too and just 1997 Aiken
Orion's volume they said the Buddhism
that I have America our update is based
on Western philosophy and more
particularly American pragmatism and
John Dewey very prominently in his mind
in the mind now I am not denying that
America had some bearing on the Western
political thought but that does not make
him a cute history that doesn't make it
try sup Buddhism a cute the clinching is
not been the waste the clinching he is
in the East the Rio Dulce that America
is disposed on with these are worth
derivative in character and I might say
it was maybe very deeply authentically
VEISHEA
and they she does not mean that the
erase of Beijing not at all he's a very
very subaltern long Brahminical nation
which is there in full a period and t
dasa and and watch him in are soon
several others analysis of making this
point so that is the rich tradition that
is coming up that is available to
embitterment and the ideal is emerging
through this day sheet edition and I'm
not denying that there was a murder
Aurra I mean all his encounter with the
waste and reconciliation to the waste
when we helped him in really developing
a proper context a formative context for
his ideal to emerge so that's the point
I would when we can discuss this and I
am really
difficulty now I can see that but we
will discuss this later
the last one is about the naivety it's a
very very very difficult area I am
really trading since yesterday with
having discretion policy and very very
very very committed scholars and see the
scholar his father and I have said later
and so there are new everybody mention
about its the mainstream dispersion in
in India is on policy yeah it's easy
okay is it okay am i audible
sufficiently okay now the delayed
politics has a problematic relationship
with the ambit phase ideal the done it
pulses which is primarily based on the
politics of social engineering by
definition rules out any possibility of
ideal and I am taking this clue from
professor Karl profit I would like to
ask questions
is there any ideal in sulfur khaliqul
proper and I think these people are
following circle powerful and not
America and that's why I said now you
they don't realize that the leaves do
not realize what are the dream and
that's the tragic part of it and thanks
Jamaica you given me the chance to speak
this openly here
so that's see that's a tragedy after the
lead politician we can be developed for
this argument later and it's a difficult
argument you might remember to himself
was a proper policy driven personality
yes fair enough we can decide that later
now yesterday's two points again make a
very very interesting case for
difference and I think I would love to
still think about it very carefully glad
again very close yeah think about it
what I think one of our medical produce
producing ideal to difference
I will paraphrasing your you may not
agree with this but that's what I got
from your presentation and therefore you
cherish the difference as an ideal and
we can also think about it I will have I
will have to elaborate on this later now
based on these files to say unless one
interesting I can't really mentioning
this there was a very very firebrand
committed Covey shy or quiet
balladeer I don't know Vaman tear duct a
womman cutter has a very strong
imagination and imagery about ambitous
idea he says America's ideas like a
ocean and I will link it up with a woman
that I later his ocean where all the
reverse all the rivers reverse up a
jainism reverse of saint saints
tradition of all pay all those rivers
they're there they are a great hurry to
really merge into the the flow very very
fast to merge into this ocean what a
strong imagination but we'll adjust one
another ideal that we have now based on
all these five to six position I have
five questions I don't have time to go
through each of them at length what is
what is the idea I am talking about in
Ambedkar first question a very very very
natural question that comes to our mind
in the quality of the decision arrival
already here how does it how does it
develop into a project of idea what is
its history ography they say history is
a basically historical question deeply
as imaginative
I already gave given some means there is
historical question historically rooted
question what are the internal and
external normative resources or
properties that constitute this ideal
that's to say whether it is completely
derivative they say that's the point
fourth point is it political that is
mediated that mediates the rift question
particularly the writ question
more generally questions of pore through
political concepts like equality liberty
and justice I think the point that
Sudipta was making was a language of
liberalism a language of Buddhism can
you really reach a Redeem idea of
Ambedkar through the language of
liberalism through the through the
concept of liberty equality and justice
I am already suggesting that is I have
not sufficient conceptual framework for
redeeming the ideal of Ambedkar who said
lose larger than this limiting concepts
and that then it enters into in the
realm of values and therefore I'll then
make two points there one is value of
Karuna that is love and my three that is
friendship if you want comrade chu but
my method is fine
make this file so that's a I think said
I will not be having enough time to
discuss this a bit complicated area of a
discussion but I can discuss this late
not later whenever it is there and the
last point is so is Buddhism based on
Karuna and my three a universal
principle universal principle or even
only mean for the Dalit wherever common
understand is above would embed with
this of any further that it I'm going to
argue no it is now his least
cancel with the delete not at all
he small concern with that the union
would say in his definition of the lid
we had a long debate this basically for
the ideal untouchable and in that
particular debate with some the Circa we
are raising this one what is who is this
ideal untouchable is to liberate this
ideal untouchable the Brahminical ideal
and the actual actual untouchable is
always relative always bow hoping to to
be the fray to the natural natural
follower of Buddhism not natural but
natural now what is the ideal oh don't
have time so okay I'll just stop there I
will just read some important thing in
Ambedkar's writings and speeches the
idea of ideal is permeated like a
running trade however it is quite
certain however it is quite centrally
defined in his too similar was the
annihilation of caste and good then his
Tama in annihilation of caste America
clearly spells out idea of ideal in
particular response to Gandhi and critic
of his understanding of Hinduism it is
all time Gandhi
you know induct Jack Porter Augmented
I'm America was invited and then later
on they are via the phone that this is
explosive material he is going to
present so if the invitation cancel and
then they then Gandhi wrote oh my god
this you how do you what do you know
about our Hinduism he asked America why
do you know why you don't know about
Hinduism but then he says then Ambedkar
gives back in debate with and with
Gandhi I think I'm he was a solitary
interlocutor of Ambedkar of anybody so
that's it in this response to Gandhi
Ambedkar lays down several they finished
our criteria for his ideal I got him to
him ideal is ideal because it is
universally applicable first criteria
ideal is ideal because it is in u.s.
therefore it is it is for everybody
including the lids he further states
that the ideal for the queue cannot be
the ideal few is the in his case is the
top of the twice-born am that's a time I
have device and see Lucius doesn't like
this stuff he wants a straightforward
message he further he is making his
point in the context of Hinduism being
ideal only for a few who occur into him
construct Hinduism in such a way so as
to extract a questions of many through
mechanical affirmation of Hinduism and
therefore anything which is imitated
followed blindly cannot be an ideal I
induce M is full of that so up the
therefore Ambika America's ideal has to
be reached and thought about seriously
through critical thinking and therefore
critical thinking is a precondition for
really thinking about the ideas not the
affirmative not the mechanical
affirmation of the text that are there
in plenty in Hinduism second Ambedkar
argues that ideal that is sustained at
the first of humilation of many cannot
be the ideal and therefore for ideal for
am Beatrice ideal what is the core
Pynchon of ideal in Ambedkar an aromatic
core principle of ideal in ambit carries
man escape and mahnovski his own were
fully and fully and America's mono skis
dignity and you can define it
differently so mono ski becomes the core
principle of his ideal and Hinduism is
full of humiliation and therefore it
cannot been ideal because there's no
respect for human being for him the
social system which contains caste
hierarchy cannot be morally defended and
hence cannot be the ideal he replied to
Gandhi on another occasion says it may
be wrong and uncharitable to judge an
ideal by its worst specimen and and
castien Varna system r2 was specimen for
Ambedkar third along with dignity Karuna
and may 3 desired two essential
constituent components of idea of ideal
in America
for America this becomes a philosophical
framework within which ideal could we
imagine and realized through through 20
she'll an idea Stan get mark the ethical
order based on May 3 and love is the
Timorese stage where it is possible to
realize realize imperfect realize a
perfect ideal in America finally um be
occurring gambit ideal is ideal because
it is realizable otherwise you too if
the ideal normally and pray to our
mothers ideal is not realizable and
that's why you know it's something which
is which exists beyond time and space so
you can't just reach them but in amulet
is reliable you might compare him with
hogs I don't know so but in Hobbes is
all realizable moral minimum that our
house is suggesting but I think they
realize EE differences not in Hobbesian
sense we can debate that later
thus Ambedkar thus in America ideal is
idle is not a historical neither it is
romantic as it is there in Gandhi so it
has to be created through creative
thinking and acting human intervention
both in politics and and and an
imagination Ambedkar's ideal idea of
ideal seems to follow certain
methodological roots and this method
there are methodological roots that the
ideal of Ambedkar is is proceeding
further the first is this historically
situated ideal that to say it doesn't
really entertain those ideas which do
not exist within time and space limits
and his debate he is permanently on
naina chore other 13 centuries Saint
water is same with Nana Shore a story
all I don't know whether you know but
Nana sure I was a Brahmin
person along with three brothers his
siblings he was out cast by his own
caste people and then he the reabsorb
and his argument is there you know I am
I can be absorbed because i'm a brama
and the core of my being his wisdom so I
am a Brahma I can be reabsorbed
America Rossum if
you can be readmitted into the order of
the brahminism and you think bruh my
exist outside this Brahma has no problem
with space and human being why don't you
come to Maharaja and stay there but
manager algorithm - Maharaja he goes to
Rama Norah I think this is drama then
therefore I think the admitted exposes
these limits of of this Brahma and
therefore it can be an ideal forum
because doesn't really it doesn't
testify itself in in terms of the time
and space the space is so important in
terms of purity pollution an ocean in
India so I think that's out the other
one is I think they also mentioned today
with a clean slate I think I think
Daniel you mid point and I think you're
right in terms of reading in the
Buddhism of Buddhism of sri lanka i
think so i think there are very
problematic cases even untouchability is
not at this death but I think I'm better
also was looking for any and looking for
two kinds of evidences one is historical
textual evidence the other one is of
practical contemporary evidence and the
practical evidence he gets only from
grabar ma he finds practices there in
1955 at 5450 he goes then you find the
Punta Seal and three Suren being
practiced by people but more importantly
he's his ideal he settles on in he
consolidate growing consolidation of the
idea is found in his own study of the
history of Buddhism he narrative ah he
is narrative izing the experiences that
Buddhism one finds with Buddhism in the
history of India you find that America
is given narratives of Buddhism how it
was great and all that - to his own
followers and you that reference is
always there you also how references of
Greek legends and all that but more
prominently it is this legend were
buddhist history that figures very
prominently in its pedagogical exercise
therefore I think for Ambedkar history
strategy I'm his T becomes pedagogy for
hamburger only through Buddhism and
that's a very immense of anybody
compelling the inside that one gets from
America now the first person I don't
sorta language of liberalism and I don't
have tended to throw throw some light on
language of liberalism or language of
Buddhism but I think I would have
mentioned I went mention about the
difference difference thing which is
very important I think I will have to
speak something about it and then our
clothes yes I will start from here
sorry just picked up I don't know I'm
under pressure I think you will give me
some time five minutes more however it
would be his it should be hasty to
conclude that the the bump that the
Burmese the Burmese context was
singularly responsible in shaping
America choice on Buddhism alongside the
time-space dimension it is also
necessary to keep in mind that is ideal
results are sensitive to its immediate
search in social historical context in
fact taking a cue from Syria took a
garage so the parrots perceptive
observational you can correct me if I'm
wrong it could be possible to argue that
it is not the ideal that chooses its
context it is in fact the context that
suja's is ideal and I think I have a
long three pages note on critical
Marxism in India but I was I'm skipping
that it is in this as amber Turkish and
America are loves new Buddhism with a
new interpretation appropriate to modern
context and that serves a lucious
pointer becomes very significant
similarly America's ideal idea of ideal
victims intelligible only in the context
of the critic of the contending notions
of ideal it is in this sense I argue
America's idea of ideal has got historic
city to eat in the same
it moves through and ultimately acquires
a unified meaning unifier meaning the
problematic term I'm using because the
most of the postmodernist will be very
very deeply angry with me now because
there's a dissolution of America into
post-modernism and I think we should
guard against it it's ultimately a quest
an unified meaning and universal appeal
through complete rejection of some ideal
and critical application of some other
ideas which will include the same
logical class this is sort of to Tom I'm
you I picked up from his class the
sunbed passed a resolution resolutely
rejects the reigning idea and I have no
time to what is reigning Attica which
then poisons us with the idea of the
ideal untouchable ideal Untouchables one
the Brahman who is you know a practicing
under gel UT against his wife I guess
it's Keith and if extreme thumbs up
untouchability that trade is ideal I'm
better
DJ's decide I ideal primarily because it
draws his sustenance from the actual
they untouchable ideal who who in a
pernicious as asymmetry of social
relationship is reduced to the level of
working carrion he's a walking can
decide in bearing term mu system I'm
using here I'm better Ambedkar also
rejects the reigning I regal the
Brahminical and the ground that he does
not motivate people it does not motivate
people to adopt the principles of poor
responsibility this is principle sits to
morally compel a person to inherit the
questions from the past that that's very
important I suppose and that's why the
difference means will may not work here
in Iran the question from the past this
these questions primarily relate to
contestation of social relationships
that seeks to perpetuate asymmetry
between the ideal and the actual
untouchable if you through this sharing
of historical questions that opens up
the possibility of imagining alternative
ideal and ultimately ultimately making
it making it once old and the ambitous
ideal amber Ambedkar Sultanate or ideals
this address as the address is the ideal
untouchable more than the actual
untouchable one would have expected the
ideal untouchable to get motivated by
the pencil of poor responsibility and
ultimately own one of America's idea of
ideal making its own but now it is with
Maharaja Sam
to cut the chart now what a tragedy it
is a universal you are reducing Itamar
with ism I know I'm only the deletes
them cells are doing it and the others
feel happy about it
I'm because ideal dissenters a strong
element of moral responsibility to
deliberate than touchable the ideal
untouchable from latest self-imposed
exclusion and to put differently
ambitous article holds out the promise
to convert the folded body in the other
body and roses very interesting paper
yesterday when about the full dead body
of an ideal untouchable into a flowing
body across time and space and what you
don't discuss much in political theory
anyway as it takes place in one of the
most influential frictional samskaara
amends notice what another another takes
you know this Gans pita body you are
unanimity samskaara wonderful takes
since Ambedkar's idea like this since
ambit cos ideal ambit curves ideals
addressee are all the moral agents
including the ideal and touchable
application our Phi del cannot be
limited only to the particular segment
of so that's what the difference
principle is a problem I'm because tries
to identify both himself and his
immediate social constituency and his
opponents with the content of his ideas
of a content of his ideal his his idea
Vidal has an inclusive character this
inclusive proposed preposition proceeds
through the political today ethical and
I'm just slightly integrate this
liberalism language of liberalism and
Buddhism he says to transform they rap
and the ideal is also an idea
Untouchables of the rough the particular
the adamant the non-negotiable other
into university reconcilable together
the together is a time I'm using it's a
funny time I'm using viewer to hurry of
it you know I just am seeking aporia not
by using meta ethical or theoretical
principle about theological principle
but through the ethical which in America
relates to mutual touch and face to face
and I'm using face of Buddha as the
ideal Thomas yesterday I got
oh yes Thomas Anton and I had an
interesting time yesterday in the union
I wasn't in spirit so this is the
article which is in America relates to
mutual touch and face to face an
immediate Punk and and the immediate and
the concrete it is in the in this sense
with thus ethical face at the present
mudra becomes the ideal for Ambedkar and
you know you can develop a theory on
what is the ethic of face and that
there's some deference to live in us and
all but in Buddha this face face is so
important - good - agent Daniel ara you
find with the smiling with a litter
booth is suffering inside by the smiling
there is no fake fake smile on the face
very authentic ontologically related to
his being which is deeply humanitarian
so that's the I think that's and that's
why there is no I think this is a very
very important point
ethical in Ambedkar is participating and
hence hold on yourself in the political
practice I think I'll leave it here I'll
just make a small point on this is what
the ideal is about the last point is
about what what does it do its equality
Liberty and and justice and and how does
how I think for Ambedkar these are all
limiting concepts concerns which exist
which are linked up to distribution
distribution itself is very very very
very problematic as we know in India I
know distribution has its own
limitations I mean the limitations are
endemic to distribution that's how
endemic to to liberalism
language of liberalism because you know
initially aesthetic state has fitted
Constitution he has difficulty here
static bureaucracy including the lead
bureaucracy everything he sees the
limitations in it you know and that's
why you must he is suggesting that you
know there is something more to state
your market the relationship of eggs
that their life this mortal life and
this a very conservative position that
one might take but I think is very
important that for Ambedkar digital
sphere which exists outside state and
market also this three
languages equality liberty and justice
and then you and therefore I think that
the sphere have cannot be regulated by
the three concept it has to be regulated
by it is actually guided by these two
pins were my three and Corona Kyle
Kaduna and my three my three actually
quickly
why doesn't really settle an active
masseuse paper was interesting why
doesn't settle for Christianity Islam
and Sikhism because you know they are
the replica of Hinduism to cut it short
the short circuit the argument that
there is a girl the hostel was not
perfectly in his own you are reproducing
what so that's what that's why it needs
mention his own thing that's the whole
reason he is really and then therefore
the touching needs the notion of
touching Christianity and in Islam is
limited and he's going beyond that I
think it's a sense of very very it's a
deeply deeply ontological equality is
talking about teach men equal treatment
a or anybody all living bodies in water
plants teas and human being that's the
Brotherhood is his love is mean for
right there it be in all I think so
ethical ethical is the ideal in with
American an ethical is Buddhism and
that's why it is it is an ideal I'll
stop
thank you very much
thanks cabal this actually gives us a
lot of time for questions so we would
take some I leave it to you to take the
questions but why don't you start thank
you enlightened speech I just wanted to
point out the last point equality am
because discourse on women's equality
started with like you know in his
writings it is reflected everywhere but
particularly regarding Buddhism the rise
and fall of ended the Hindu women in
maha bodhi article 51 he wrote that as
encounter to the women women's journal
there is that they know Buddhism was
responsible that don't fall off in the
women so then he goes lost weight clause
citing the example someone is pretty how
degraded women's status in the society
and goes on constructing Buddhism for
the women's equality how we take a
created a platform but I found that you
know this am Beatrice discourse of
women's equality or the place of women
in Buddhism or the with this Buddhism
Buddhism contribution to the women's
equality was not taken forward by the
following discourses how do we look into
this kind of a thing
because it's raised there and it was not
taken further by the following scholars
if there are questions which are related
then I think we should I'm glad that you
brought out the point that the Western
mind holds Ambedkar only secondary to
some Western leaders in the
international context and in the Indian
context only next to candy
I suppose I'm right when I say this and
what I find is Ambedkar as a universal
humanist has never you know encountered
contradictions in his own statements are
deeds but where is Gandhi I find he
advocates peaceful non-cooperation and
he has experimented in South Africa and
next he experiments in India now entire
world says oh it's a good theory that
everyone can follow but while he didn't
apply the same to the Dalits he did he
never said to college please don't
cooperate with the Hindus this is not at
all universal so he is partial parochial
I just want to classify that way one the
second point I want to make us so why
somebody also made a point that why
Ambedkar embraced Buddhism compared to
many other religion i-i-i-i don't have
much theories on it but I feel i I don't
also believe in reincarnation but I
don't see any difference between
bhutanam Baker and that's how he has you
know embraced it Buddhism these are the
two parts
my name is thinkers Javits and my
subject is sustainable development and
my question is about the fast forward to
today and tomorrow India has the
potential of becoming world power number
one Asia power number one it has
difficulty in surpassing China because
exactly what we heard here today the
question is about technology becoming a
new religion for India I my question to
you is if untouchability is a real
problem
or rather unjustified feeling of
superiority of the Brahmin that is a
real problem
I'm not acclamation I'm an actor
whatever works it works for me I
listened to the whole conference my
question is this I never thought about
it the Indians do not seem to accept to
take the issue of untouchability to the
international arena where as apartheid
because I study one speaker said North
we can't take it to sanctions regime
which is international but whereas if
you listen to Desmond Tutu he says it is
apartheid it seems like they are more
interested make it international is it
because I don't know why untouchability
should have not been easy because we are
lacking like cases like some of those
radical sake he and some others
incidents that shocks the conscience of
the human beings I'm wondering why I'm
not here to advocate but I just the
thought in my head
you know finally just say you concluded
with the the eyes idea is the face of
Buddha and also you said there to
smiling and I would say that just it's
piling and the tolerating voice raises
on Martin Luther King jr. was able to
construct a an anti racism you know in a
way in his own style tolerating unlike
that is it like a smiling denoting that
toleration to a disability or atrocity
like that
I just with that ideal he just focused
Empire you know movement and I don't
think that the implication whatever the
impact we have street we living in India
in a place as big threat to brahmanism
are to try some anything anything like
the caste system just smile in thing you
know our concept he made the idea it
includes a threat to in tourism the
picture is not just maybe it's ice not
materialistic but it's more than
materialist thank you so going for
smiling buddha you must go for angry
with the so okay okay we'll do that i'm
with you and i of my i debate with look
mitra and others what my some debate
took place sometimes so we'll go for
angry with them with you but but there's
a piece of the purpose even a smiling
buddha as they go in the foreground ITT
presupposes certain ethical of
can behave yeah so I say it's a
and they party with Indian Parliament
enacted the law prohibited all the
Commerce performance we have done this
with sweets that the one our leader came
up and cried like anything in the anger
that's why this I said that wasn't just
like simply like smiling Buddha know the
ultimate is smiling you know and also
you find that you know when you are
smiling you are already showing where
you are already implicated in several
normative vocabulary in this smiling
it's not simply a empty smile it's a
smile which is loaded with enough
historical possesses mood motivated by
this anomaly to her Calgary like you
know we need more people through love
reasoning or reasoning out with them
showing them that difficulties and
faults you just cannot use this you
cannot you cannot you cannot acquire
this so you cannot achieve this through
this state machineries are institutions
you got the life which is beyond
institutions cannot be handled by these
language of liberalism it has to be
language of Buddhism that's the ultimate
but to know the problematic area is that
of what does America so yes
what is the role notion of politics and
what is the notion of state in him we
will have to discuss that he's already
disappointed with the existing
structures that doesn't promise anything
and so but you know us he's he's already
working on that but and an RP and other
things are there but not that they are
not the sufficient condition for
achieving this so I think that let us
see that smiling is the complete final
reflection of what Buddha wants to
achieve actually and the process is
early follow this smiling smiling is not
a it says fully it is emitted smiling it
is so to say it's not a fake or empty
smile as we find in in in more in
modernity of today Chirac you should we
stop now so no I do I do
no in that case can I just say something
okay in that case what I had I had these
two three points I yeah actually there
was one point which I want you to
address particularly also about the
women yeah there's a woman you seen I
mean see in America's Buddhism you find
that the references to women becoming
very very significant addressing of
Buddhism in America but I think he what
Ambedkar also is pointing out it the
debate between boudin boudin and ananda
actually you know it is a very difficult
debate that took place on and then with
the with the wasn't in favor of really
accepting women into the sangha because
five hundred and five five for fifty
years that's the if you a debate women
in the sangha and they rate up with the
other will only fire on that five
hundred years
if you don't adamant it will you five
thousand years that's it but I'm not
aware of a reason are with the Buddha
actually it's a nothing you are a
religion of equality and I'll how can we
keep women out because use a very
problematic thing so and then what the
access that an ammeter carries forward
that dialogue we say different thing
that the today's with this so-called
with this do not really follow that
anyways so that's see that's should be
fueled and there and then one final
point is this technology I think you
said very interesting we observe I make
a superior Brahmins and Untouchables are
two different things
untouchable you the matter of technology
and and that's for itself but I think
that chilled in India India is the
election this is a very amazing
incredible country actually which really
mixes with technology with Brahmanism
for example you go to Abra Xerox shop
the photocopying and it is owned by the
Brahmin in sahaja Pony and a guitar
maker will really confirm this they
won't be she won't accept the
certificate because the caste
certificate
so you don't know that is much okay okay
I think you know a few more questions
first you and to a few from there but
you should be concise in your questions
and then I'll give some time to go
online and quickly my questions link to
this one statement I want to preserve
grow to really respond a religious
persecution is not a thing of today it
is as ancient as the religion itself it
rised and purifies the persecuted who
have themselves launched in their faith
the versions can patiently bear
persecution they are bound to come trim
punt at the end so this is the statement
of Gandhiji meaning persecution has to
be patiently you should pursue it you
should still have a strong faith and you
are also talking about smiling is there
any link that persecution patient
hearing of persecution can bring a
positive result my question is that in
1956 dr. Ambedkar absolutely Islam in
Shanthi
and both region don't have a caste
system by rule and what is the this one
instead of both religion how quickly are
you a better knowledge of Islam so I'll
get back to my name is Sahaj I just want
to make one comment on what you said is
people who favor Gandhi and project him
as an idealist who had ideals his ideal
was Rama Raja my very question is you
know Ram Raja is not really an ideal
Raja to begin with because during the
time of Rama who was who is believed to
be an incarnation of God he himself
assassinated Shambhu Shudra for
practicing
penance which was not which you know he
was not supposed to practice and
secondly Sita in spite of her being
loyal to Rama
all his life he made her taken apprecia
so such a Raja cannot be my name is
Yogeshwara I had a privilege to be in
Nagpur when dr. Ambedkar converted to
Buddhism there he gave a very clear
definite we converted Buddhism which is
the question has been asked constantly
here
he said that dignity is a primary
element for every human being number two
the great message of equality justice
and fraternity was propagated by the son
of India Lord Buddha and the Vantage of
us have where at one time in history
where the rulers of India the Nagas we
need our the dignity back we need our
pride back and this is why we are
following Lord Buddha that was a comment
I wanted to make it one second thing is
under Gandhi Gandhi was a propagator of
a caste system he promoted in the caste
system and caste means violence cost
means the degradation of the human
beings and violence violence means
Buddha the Gandhi cannot be a peace
apostle he is when he promotes the caste
system and I admire the great work of
Gopal Raju over the years and I
commissioned a team for an external
presentation of today's debate on dr.
Baker as idealism thank you speaking to
the boy since you mentioned difference I
just want to ask you a large question
which is this is not a baker's language
that's not the issue but which we knew
and me difference my mind is not a
question of segments alone
difference is a means of constituting
the universal it is central to the
Constitution of the universe and so I
just wonder what you make of that in
terms of thinking about very quickly
following on the prior question I want
to ask you I know that you wanted to in
a sense take on breaker in and out
latest time I want to and we heard about
Gandhi I want to actually hear a little
bit more about a bit current Marx
because I think this has something to do
with the way that you're troubling this
question of difference and also what
you're saying about the issue of
co-responsibility
because if indeed we have to think about
Ambedkar is practicing a certain form of
imminent thought then the question of
how he thinks dialectically and and what
it is he wants to constitute in terms of
the ideal I think also becomes quite
important and his thought in a sense has
to then be distinguished or seen in
conflict or conversation with Marx and
you said you had a bit bit there about
maps I won't ask you a quick question
you were referring to segmented ways of
reading up on Beth cut service
constitutionalism etc and I wanted to
know how you would in fact read the
ideal not not true Buddhism alone but
the ways in which I'm Beth cos
transformation of Buddhism is rewriting
of Buddhism also entered into that the
political world he inhabited and how in
fact it might have transferred over in
two ways that he conceived of the Indian
Constitution go politics yeah I should
say that you know the the choice of
Buddhism for Ambedkar is not
one time choice it is emerging through a
very painful process of direct
evaluation of options that are available
including constitutions that is to say
that I am I would not say a Lambert who
would not say that actually Laura there
is say what is constitutional expression
of Buddhism that's what they say
and they are not wrong in saying so
because all these principles of their
dignity and and all that is there so it
is a reflection in Constitution we have
to accept that I am NOT but I am saying
what is not in Constitution and which is
there in Buddhism of Ambedkar he is
something which is a normative question
like for example there is no law which
says right right against untouchability
is there is there a right to touch I
have a right to touch that right is not
there Shona
so I think that right that question is
found only in the ethical not in the
constitutional and political and that's
why I think this will there is already
moving beyond these limited versions of
you know redeeming up ideal so that's I
think but you are right that it is it is
already reflected simultaneously side by
side in the Constitution but is moving I
it as just as you know in full a a
number kids are interesting debate
actually when I didn't touch upon it and
I have for all the important questions
anyway because I am looking at Janaki
and the chairperson you know in well
I'll cede all of my time to you so there
is this he's integrating what the
critical impulses from all these
traditions but it's he's also going
beyond those traditions actually like he
may not agree with what fool I had said
about the Nemec that nearly the notion
of near America and fully Ambedkar made
her agree with that no because no way of
I agree but he is not discounting on a
fully and that's why I think it is easy
this ideal is emerging as an ulterior
ideal not at the cost of really
submerging America's article into the
dead water
he's not a flirt because he's actually
integrating it so I think that's his
ideal is worked out through the
historical impulses and also there's a
very strong area from the same tradition
he's also is linked up to Karaman to
Karim is a Buddhist anyway they're more
Arab that you know our friend hassel
Erin Murray has worked out this
combination so there are several guess I
just thought the waist it's not purely
the waist I think that point is may have
still still it because some some more
explanation so that's the other one
needs about what hmm Gianna said about
this does not difference really
constitute the urge for universal that's
the point you're making I think yes you
are I think you cannot really really
visualize any way in the were self if
you don't have the notion of false our
notion of sameness but sameness is
sameness is there you don't want to
become like the Brahman you want to be a
different do not have it so for that you
are using difference to really undercut
the significance of the sameness but you
are not really finding the difference
you are moving ahead of the of the
difference and that is what the
alternative lies you know if you are
going mere dog were going beyond the
difference you got difference if it is
the difference and I'm looking for
making reference to yesterday's speech
you know if did Ambika really suggest
different nation fertile it the answer
is no because the ethical would never
permit it
but as he wants to convert the human
being in the other the the other is the
ideal untouchable and that is what just
a bit philosophical strength of America
he is not subscribing in and system is
the right word suggesting Buddhism for
the delete yes that is one and women
that's what but more importantly those
who are suffering were ill a cast of
mind so to say okay so I think there is
a and the difference is also ethical as
discussion yesterday a deep France and
record difference has to be recognized
the recognition becomes a ethical
challenge but I think the lift question
is more than the recognition and
therefore I think that adult will be
better again
should we produce the lead-in to a
difference and Margaret eyes him as you
use that one the answer is no it will be
it will be impossible I think that these
are questions that will take up and
whatever determines and now my are angry
with Islam will do both at that and the
dialectics I think there's a there's a
very interesting I know there's a very
interesting conversation between a
mezuzah man Ambedkar ISM so to say and
you know I must do this dialectics in
Jonathas those speeches that were
published by Aaron calmly in in in that
book you may not like it this is the
most delicate and know the live with
this talk about this see the trajectory
of ultimate is through French Revolution
then the Russian Revolution the ultimate
is the Buddhist revolution and this is
dialectic happening there so you start
rushing and I at that point retching and
reaching universal at that point I would
explain I think we'll explain it later
later is always a good term so so that
and then he is using a very interesting
metaphor Moutai metaphor about puran
poli and the puran poli
the pyrenees the russian revolution but
there is more than foreign body this is
buddhist but we do not really quote any
time he is acknowledging the historical
significance of fringe revolution but
not enough going ahead then he is
acknowledging the contribution the
russian federation not in am going ahead
and this is very enriching the
interesting dialectic happening in
america and i only wish that he had
survived some more years you drive in a
different story altogether
but let's see we take it further in
whatever small way I am NOT concluding
we can have some discussion
yeah yeah edges on it also enlarged and
civic armies comment about on both
curves consistency versus Gandhi's
contradictions but I wanted what I want
to point out is what's fascinating is
that the very fact that vid Gandhi had
all these contradictions is is openly
acknowledged by and even celebrated but
by those who are so bent on celebrating
Gandhi so the fact that he had these
contradictions as thinking it's it's a
paradox but the thing that's so
wonderful about him you know he
accomplished contradictions and this I
think goes with the served family
resemblance of of thoughts that had been
very prevalent I think that the moment
for them is passed but the thought that
heterogeneity fluidity flexibility are
necessarily subaltern strategy or
necessarily work against power the
flipside being you know power is
necessarily monolithic monological rigid
but but in fact you know I think it is
quite clear that power also operates by
means of heterogeneity by means of
paradox by means of fluidity by means of
flexibility one last question
Thomas yeah it is about the face just a
continuation yesterday nobody I am your
invocation of the buddha's face and the
smile and the destruction I mean that
that smile can mean many things can also
mean as my neighbor just said a mocking
kind of gesture yes it can mean that
kind of it's a satanic smile yes so but
but my real question is in today in in
India it's not the smile of the Buddha
that is important for the Maharashtra
for the Dalits it's the face of yeah and
his demeanor which is also a self faint
smile dignified calm what do we make of
that you are very skillfully planting
tensions but
anyway response okay I have a very very
difficult question I've I don't want I
want to let you duck this question I
don't want to answer this question but
anyway I have to have some as Gann said
to you know cities are for to keep
taking the olivet so ruthlessly I'm not
ruthlessly here because the Buddhist
might pass in it I think there is a
Altima to there are the you evolution of
face has to be taken into consideration
and I think you see the mudra of
Ambedkar here actually is wearing
achiever and everything that for
ensuring an ease in a Buddhist image
actually this is a merger of the two and
now that that's a the ideal is the
actual if it is actually there's no need
for discussion is that ideal you are
really trying to reach which is possible
now therefore I think the ideal is as a
very very important political function
to perform that really keeps motivating
you towards your goal if there's no
ideal is a deafness and no future so I
didn't and also it is really also
sustains your systems creativity in you
why do you think poor really to sustain
and they don't reload
why that's the that's why it is there's
a logic in all in this you know
therefore I think our our ultimate idea
used to how that everybody's happy why
should somebody I'm sure somebody
walking somebody's agony why that's not
the order that's not the decent so that
and this answer is not right but that's
not the other we're looking for we are
looking for the production of that very
very honest authentic smile on the face
without any qualification attribution so
that you don't have to produce a fake
smile while you are shaking hands the
modernity does all that in any way and
also anonymity somebody mentioned this
point I think I know I've allows just
made this find interesting anonymity and
I did he is anonymity an ideal input in
Ambedkar I think that's not the case he
suggested her to move away from me
- the energy today not even city to the
city's sleep up that Freudian slip there
one last question which are segue nicely
into the sri lankan lunch that we have
waiting for you so one last question
it's very short oh how are you going to
prevent I could have stood up for you
sir how are you going to are you
concerned that idealisation is going to
morph into a dedication of the Buddha I
think I was I was already this question
again because you know for Delhi today
in the country yeah I don't I have
become an ideal that's I don't want to
say anything more than that sir
that's it yeah a very very disturbing
thing so that's all thank you thank you
thank you so since I can see that seated
all of my time to go pal I'll make this
anytime I'll make this very brief in
good South Asian tradition we're going
to serve you a Sri Lankan meal and by
that I literally mean serve you South
Asia staff volunteers students we're
going to stand behind the counter and
serve you all a Sri Lankan meal it's all
out there thank you all so very much for
coming it's been a wonderful day and a
half and hopefully as soon as I can get
my fall fund drive started I can do this
again next year with all of your help so
much thank you all very much